2 to 3! Such a fun age,
but they are super busy.
So here's my suggestion for gifts for kids ages 2 to 3.
My favorite idea for family to give to you is memberships to aquariums,
the little gym, children's museum.
Stuff to get you out of the house and keep your kid active.
Next I would start saving your boxes and food items and let them play
grocery store. You've already bought the item,
you just don't throw it away.
Pack it up with tape, make sure it's clean,
and give them maybe a basket to throw stuff in and play grocery store.
Along the same lines,
this is a great time to start introducing care tasks.
So this cute little Dyson vacuum.
It's about $24.
It actually sucks stuff up and it's a great gift for two year olds.
They would also get a kick out of a feather duster
and a family favorite of my house.
Solo cups and balls.
You can get fun colored balls like this and the games are endless.
We also like doing fun bath time stuff.
So bath paint huge.
Also big packs of glow sticks,
disco bath and all sorts of pouring stuff. Hope this helps!